I need you to pretend you with me see
that woman over there she's my accent I
can't be seen alone nice try
sure this works for you all the time but
I'm really not interested jack begging
aren't you going to introduce me to your
little friend
I'm Maria Jack fiancee Wow Wow good stop
being rejected in Portuguese is on I
will never live with anyone again oh my
god I ought to keep my furniture pieces
in oh the big cross don't protect us
from the evil eye oh my damn we can be
overwhelming stay away from Maria hate
me they just need to get to know you
Oh Senor Maria someone who would fight
with me don't tell me you're one of
those superstitious freak takes a moment
at the grocery store gave me the evil
eye the evil eye does not eat today do
you have any idea how foolish you sound
right now this is not the man for you
why don't you tell us what you know
about poetry oh yeah Portugal's
number-one export must be beautiful
women
Maria mrs. Munez mr. Moniz you are a
lucky man that's some good Portuguese
jeans right there and I'd love to get in
on that action you know I mean if you're
with your daughter not your wife how
could you you know your family makes me
very nervous
what does his mouth he's got a counter
oh my god
you two don't belong together make me
understand why you need senior Maria in
your life because she's never wrong
or she's wrong about us no she's not
back I know breakups suck let's go to
new girlfriends - hurry love jack
or the ladies not my future can be very
frightening putting back miss out on
something wonderful
all night doesn't feel real to me best
first date ever a date with misfortune I
thought mr. Bojangles was fixed